hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
the psychologist max wertheimer was
friends with albert einstein
in 1934 he sent einstein a letter with
the following puzzle
there's an old car that needs to go up
and down a hill
the hill is one mile going up
and because the car is old it can only
average 15 miles per hour going up the
hill
the hill is also one mile going down
but the car may be able to go faster
because it's going down the hill
the question is
how fast must the car go going down the
hill so that it averages 30 miles per
hour for the entire two mile trip
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so before i get to the solution i want
to provide some context this puzzle
comes from a 1934 letter albert einstein
had already been recognized with the
nobel prize in physics in 1921.
in 1905 he had produced four amazing
results including the photoelectric
effect brownian motion special
relativity and energy and mass
equivalence summarized by the equation e
equals m c squared
any one of these works would have been a
lifetime achievement and he produced all
four in one year
so you might think if there's anyone
who'd be able to solve puzzles in his
head it would be albert einstein
but even he had trouble
this puzzle was not immediately obvious
to einstein as he wrote he didn't see
the trick until he calculated the answer
so i think there are two lessons from
this
first even einstein had to work
carefully to solve math problems and
second he enjoyed this simple puzzle
just like the many simple puzzles that i
post in my videos so i'm sure everyone
will enjoy all of the puzzles that i
post even if they want harder puzzles
they'll appreciate some of the easier
problems just like albert einstein did
this story is told in gerd gigerenzer's
book wrist savvy how to make good
decisions
so now let's solve the problem
we'll work backwards
first we'll ask what's the time
necessary to average 30 miles per hour
for the entire two mile trip
so we set up the equation 30 miles per
hour is equal to 2 miles divided by t
we'll solve for the time and we get this
is equal to 1 15 of an hour
as there are 60 minutes in an hour this
is equal to 4 minutes
now
let's solve for the time the car takes
going up the hill
well the car takes for one mile
a 15 mile per hour average
this simplifies to be one fifteenth of
an hour which again is four minutes
so we see the car takes four minutes
just to go up the hill and it needs to
take 4 minutes for the entire trip to
average 30 miles per hour
and this leads to a surprising
conclusion
the car must take 0 minutes going down
to get 30 miles per hour for the entire
trip
therefore this is a trick question it's
not possible for the car to average 30
miles per hour for the entire two mile
trip unless it takes zero minutes to get
down the hill
that would only be possible if the car
could travel infinitely fast and we know
that's not possible because nothing can
travel faster than the speed of light
as einstein wrote not until calculating
did i notice there is no time left for
the way down so this is a delightful
little brain teaser that even albert
einstein enjoyed did you figure out this
problem thanks for watching these math
videos which can be watched for free on
youtube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to the newest videos
and email me a puzzle or math topic
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise you can
grab a mug or t-shirt you can check out
my books which are linked in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support